bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat la france dispose t-elle encore du
meilleur système de santé au monde
c'est la question à laquelle les
sénateurs ont essayé de répondre ce
matin dans un rapport récent et bien l'
agence de presse bloomberg place la
france en huitième position en tenant
compte est bien de l'espérance de vie ou
encore du coût de la sécurité sociale
par habitant par rapport au pib
dans ce contexte à la demande du groupe
des radicaux de gauche les sénateurs ont
débattu dans l'hémicycle à ce sujet en
présence de la secrétaire d'état chargé
de la lutte contre l'exclusion ségolène
neuville alors un débat qui a été
évidemment l'occasion d'entendre
quelques cocorico sur notre système de
santé en france mais aussi et bien de
poser les questions qui fâchent
et d'évoquer les limites notamment
financières de ce système
je vous propose tout de suite de
retrouver ces débats dans l'hémicycle
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
thème la france dispose t-elle encore du
meilleur système de santé au monde c'est
une demande du groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
monsieur gilbert barbier pour le groupe
r d est ce vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
madame annamites présidente madame le
ministre
les chers collègues c'est celle de santé
français est il le meilleur du monde
cette interrogation semblera certes un
peu provocatrice ou à indécente
comment en effet osé remettre en cause
cette notion ancrée dans notre histoire
nationale
cette assertion qui datent du siècle des
lumières ce siècle qui a vu la naissance
de la médecine moderne dans le tablier
de bichat comme l'écrivent et gustave
flaubert développé par la suite par
l'inec bretonneau trop chômage indique
claude bernard rue pasteur même si celui
ci n'était pas médecin et bien d'autres
encore
faudrait citer tous les grands noms de
la médecine française qui depuis ont
perpétré la place de la france dans le
maelström mondial de la médecine moderne
être les meilleurs du monde
être champion dans quelques disciplines
sportives ou autres flatte toujours
notre orgueil cocardier de cela n'a pas
grand sens dans le domaine si
particulier qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
et le pathos ne suffit plus pour en
temps il est plus que nécessaire de
s'auto-évaluer pour éventuellement se
remettre en cause sans faux fuyants et
c'est là peut-être notre rôle de
parlementaire
il s'agit bien évidemment pas de faire
ici le procès de qui que ce soit notant
que la responsabilité des uns et des
autres me semble partagée dans cette
évolution larvée ce glissement insidieux
cette lente dégradation de notre système
de santé que je crois percevoir il
serait déjà pertinent de le reconnaître
et essayer ensemble d'y porter remède si
je puis dire
didier sicard dans un entretien en 98
avait bien esquissé le réponse à cette
question en séparant la médecine en tant
que soins à la personne et la santé
publique
je le cite la médecine française est
fondée sur une relation médecin-malade
individuel
c'est une médecine cher mais c'est une
médecine efficace et il poursuivait
parlant de la santé publique qu'ils
disent aussi du soin la france est un
pays jacobin qui aime diriger du haut
vers le bas qui aiment envoyer des
directives aux préfets à l'époque
qu'aujourd'hui on dirait des abruzzes
ars tout est vécu comme si l'information
qui remontait du bas était une
information dénonciatrice policière
et plus loin il a ajouté encore la
france est totalement absent dans le
domaine de l'épidémiologie depuis les
réformes se sont succédé le plus souvent
se contredisant pour aboutir aujourd'hui
à une situation dangereuse qui est la
perte de confiance est le doute de nos
concitoyens dans ce qui est le bien le
plus précieux de l'individu la santé de
nombreuses études réalisées par des
organismes d'horizons les plus variés on
t'aime aboutissent à un même constat
sous les vocables différent d'ailleurs
le système est dans une impasse
il est à bout de souffle il est victime
d'une dégradation patente et j'en passe
beaucoup d'économistes se sont penchés
sur les causes de cette dégradation
il ne servirait à rien de l'ignorer en
regrettant là encore l'absence de
données épidémiologiques global certes
on peut s'enorgueillir de quelques
pépites de très haut niveau
le centre de recherche de services de
notoriété mondiale de plusieurs pôles
d'excellence dans les domaines et plus
sophistiqués de la médecine
contemporaine par une action concertée
en général entre l'inserm et le milieu
suite à l'eau universitaire même s'il a
aussi des problèmes existent je
consacrerai mon propos d'aujourd'hui
elle dispense de soins
le premier problème bien sûr condition
de les autres concernent le financement
notre système nous sommes pourtant à des
pays qui consacrent une part importante
de son pib à la santé
il y aurait-il donc un mésusage de cet
engagement financier
depuis des décennies les gouvernements
successifs courte après un équilibre des
comptes
et essaie d'endiguer un déficit quasi
constant auquel ils pallient par des
mesures financières sans pour autant
aboutir
nous ne pouvons plus année après année a
beau leur dire cette dette transmise aux
générations suivantes
pour notre propre confort sanitaire il
faut donc dépenser moins et surtout
mieux ou différemment
quitte à revoir lors d'un retour à
meilleure fortune de leurs économies le
mode de financement de la protection
sociale en général les bases actuelles
reposent reposant sur l'activité sont
trop restrictives
le transfert vers un financement aux
basses plus large est entamée il doit se
poursuivre mais se pose alors une
première interrogation qui fait
immédiatement débat la gestion paritaire
est elle encore adapté mais ce n'est pas
l'objet de ce propos aujourd'hui après
la création de sécurité sociale en 1945
les trente glorieuses ont permis
d'assurer un financement expansionniste
de la santé les difficultés vont
commencer dans les années 80 avec la
montée du chômage
en 1995 ordonnance juppé font entrer une
régulation étatique des dépenses avec la
création de l'ondam qui aujourd'hui
encore en cas dans la dépense publique
de santé
alors depuis des années pour limiter des
dépenses il est procédé budget après
budget un des coups de rabot dans des
secteurs souvent les mêmes d'ailleurs où
certes des économies peuvent être
réalisées
mais cette méthode atteint ses limites
et il faut avoir le courage et la
volonté politique de reprendre
l'ensemble de l'organisation de la
dispense de soins
cette dispense de soins se divisent
traditionnellement deux parties
l'hôpital et la médecine de ville à bord
dont celui qui est considéré comme tabou
l'hôpital qu'en est il le constatons
essentiellement un trop grand nombre
d'établissements par rapport aux pays
voisins des chu il y en a de très grands
très performant dans la plupart des
disciplines et d'autres qui peuvent
exceller dans quelques spécialités mais
sont aussi absents dans beaucoup de
domaines de la scène
fyk internationale aussi pour exister ou
simplement subsister certains services
hospitaliers admettent et traitent des
patients porteurs de l'affection souvent
banale avec à la clé un prix de journée
excessif privant ainsi les hôpitaux
généraux et les établissements privés
d'une activité dispensés à moindre coût'
je sais que pour assumer la charge
d'enseignement qui lui est dévolu le chu
de rassembler toutes les pathologies de
la plus simple la plus compliquée mais
peut-être que des stages mieux organisés
dans les établissements périphériques ou
en cabinet permettrait de contourner ce
problème il faut repenser le rôle du chu
qui doit être un modèle d'excellence
pour les spécialités les plus pointues
et non un établissement de proximité
j'ajoute qu'une économie importante en
résultera s'agissant des hôpitaux
généraux
nous savons qu'ils connaissent qu'ils
connaîtront dans les années à venir les
plus grandes difficultés essentiellement
en raison de la pénurie de médecins
spécialistes de qualité intéressés par
la carrière hospitalière
depuis des années dans certaines
disciplines les vacances de postes se
multiplient
lui est alors fait appel à du personnel
médical dont la compétence ni même la
validité des diplômes d'ailleurs n'a à
aucun moment été vérifiés il faut coûte
que coûte pourvoir les postes pour
éviter la fermeture des services
et je ne parle pas du recours à ces
vacataires qui viennent faire des
remplacements à des tarifs ruineux pour
les finances des établissements il est
urgent et impératif de mettre en place
des commissions de recrutement pour
stopper la dégradation du niveau médical
surtout lorsqu'il faut pourvoir des
chefferies de service les conséquences
de cette situation sont évidentes
c'est une perte de confiance de la
patientèle locale c'est une perte de
crédibilité vis-à-vis des médecins
généralistes du secteur
la notoriété de l'ensemble de
l'établissement en pâtit et le recours à
l'hôpital devient
pis-aller nous devons admettre nous
devons admettre que l'on ne peut pas
faire tout partout et tout bien la
notion de proximité un mauvais argument
pour maintenir ici ou là des services à
faible activité de ce fait peu attractif
pour les médecins quand on connaît les
différentiels financier qui s'offrent
aux meilleurs d'entre eux je rappelle
ici
le recensement fait par le professeur
guy vallancien en 2006 sur la qualité
des plateaux techniques 130 d'entre eux
avaient été jugés insuffisants
médiocre voire dangereux aucune suite
n'a été donnée à cette enquête
quelle réponse sera à portée de main à l
étude toute récente de la cour des
comptes sur la sécurité dans les
maternités
faudra-t-il attendre d'autres orthez
certes ne faut pas faire la même d'un
mâle gamme mais nous devons analyser
plus finement l'écho de ce taux de
mortalité périnatale peu enviable pour
notre pays
folon repenser la carte cartographier
hospitalière en associant le réseau
public le réseau privé malheureusement
l'absence d'open data sur les données
détenues par l'assurance maladie ne
permet pas d'évaluer le différentiel de
morbidité entre les établissements et
les services
ce ne sont pas les publications
annuelles paraissant dans les
hebdomadaires qui sont importantes pour
évaluer correctement mais l'ensemble des
données détenues par l'assurance maladie
que l'on ne connaît pas
chacun le sait très bien la principale
inégalités d'accès aux soins n'est pas
un problème de territoire mais bien de
la qualité de la prise en charge qu'elle
soit initiale en urgence ou en différé
nos concitoyens c'est bien logique
veulent bénéficier les meilleures prises
en charge
quitte à faire quelques kilomètres de
plus n'en déplaise aux élus locaux
d'ailleurs cette réforme hospitalière
devrait être d'envergure notre président
gérard larcher évalué en 2008 à près de
60 mille le nombre de lits
d'hospitalisation excellente elle
depuis les progrès de la médecine la
chirurgie ambulatoire permettent de
confirmer ce chiffre
voire de l'amplifier même si quelques
restructurations ont été effectués il
reste encore beaucoup à faire
un grand nombre de reconversion pourrait
d'ailleurs encore être réalisées même si
en matière de santé l'emploi local ne
peut être une variable d'ajustement du
réseau il est urgent de repenser la
prise en charge des différentes
pathologies pour une meilleure
efficacité à l'image d'un plan qui
marche bien que le plan cancer
alors on assite paradoxalement un
recours accrû excessive des malades vers
l'hôpital et spécialement des les
services d'urgence la caisse d'assurance
maladie estime ainsi que 650 mille
patients 2012 ce sont ce qui représente
une dépense de 2 milliards d'euros
faut donc se poser la question de la
permanence des soins
les parois de conséquences de la
démographie médicale et des conditions
d'exercice alors tout un tas de
problèmes se posent que les difficile de
développer d'une manière importante
aujourd'hui numerus clausus féminisation
mode de vie des professionnels
contraintes d'installation géographique
concentration maison de santé
rémunération à l'acte la pathologie
statut du médecin responsabilité pénale
principe de précaution gratuité totale
ou partielle autant de questions qui ne
peuvent pas être traitées séparément ou
partiellement le problème est bien
global il s'agit aujourd'hui de faire un
choix majeur de société le dialogue
singulier médecin-malade doit-il
disparaître dans une dans une situation
qui si elle qui pose problème de
situation qui doit être résolu par le
service de santé publique
alors bien entendu la pathologie
aujourd'hui
pose le problème de la formation des
patients cette formation des patients
portent essentiellement sur le fait que
pour kraft avait dit que l'art guérir
c'était un art est ce que c'est devenu
une science on peut légitimement
s'interroger lorsque la formation
initiale comporte 16 sciences
fondamentales
il existe actuellement 32 spécialités
médicales différentes ces spécialités
chirurgicales et encore dix autres
qualifications
le corollaire de cette emprise des
scientifiques sur la médecine est un peu
peu de place laissé aujourd'hui dans le
cursus initial à la clinique ou contact
avec le malade et pas seulement avec la
maladie je reprends encore là les
paroles du professeur sicard la clinique
les étudiants ne l'aiment pas car elle
semble archaïque et l'obligent à
affronter encore humain avec tout ce que
cela peut comporter de gênes de
répulsion de malaise il faut revoir la
formation initiale pour que les jeunes
médecins apprennent le chemin du
dialogue singulier le mot clinique nous
dire lee est cette formation au chevet
du patient qui fait cruellement défaut
même si bien sûr aujourd'hui les examens
complémentaires de biologie d'imagerie
ou autres sont en appoint diagnostic
essentiel incontestable mais trop
souvent inutiles et coûteux reste aussi
à produire dans l'enseignement initial
une initiation à la psychologie
quand aujourd'hui le malade de savoir
être préparé au parcours de soins qui
l'attend pour les maladies chroniques
omniprésente qui ont remplacé les
pathologies aiguës aujourd'hui plus
facilement maîtrisé si les difficultés
rencontrées peuvent être reçus
rapidement par un généraliste sont une
des causes du renoncement à se soigner
se tourner vers l'hôpital
malheureusement les choses ne
s'améliorent pas lorsqu'il faut recourir
un spécialiste
certaines disciplines sont véritablement
s'illustrer
d'autres très menacé
pour obtenir un rendez vous avec un
gynécologue obstétricien l'ophtalmo le
bdia un cardiologue ou bien d'autres
spécialistes il faut s'armer de patience
les délais d'attentes sont une des
causes du renoncement aux soins
que dire à cet instant de la formation
médicale continue sinon que nous sommes
là aussi dans un domaine parfaitement
empirique pratiquement laissé à la
conscience professionnelle de chaque
médecin de chaque professionnel de santé
il n'est pas facile d'aborder ce
problème
au risque de se heurter aux des ego mais
il est urgent que les intéressés se
saisissent de ce problème surtout on
assure le contrôle et l'évaluation ne
serait-il pas du rôle du conseil de lob
de prendre en charge ce problème dans
d'autres domaines s'il est encore trop
tôt pour évaluer les conséquences de la
réforme de la biologie médicale
force est de constater que la politique
restrictive en matière d'autorisation
d'équipement lourd d'imagerie retarde la
prise en charge et le traitement des
maladies graves
les délais d'attentes de près d'un mois
dans certaines régions sont
difficilement supportable par les
patients autre domaine encore nous
sommes malheureusement sur les premières
marches du podium jeux je fais référence
à la consommation de psychotropes
d'une manière générale à la consommation
de médicaments la commission des
affaires sociales a bien voulu nous
charger monsieur le président le non
merci
avec yves daudigny d'essayer d'y voir
plus clair sur cette clause
problématique
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
dans quelques mois les il est bien
évident que les nouvelles avancées
concernant les biotechnologies les
traitements personnalisés
les molécules coûteuse imposeront
inévitablement à notre société des choix
économiques
si j'insiste il souhaite deux problèmes
majeurs de notre système il en est un
autre tout aussi important
malheureusement ne le sommes pas des
champions et qui relève bien la santé
publique c'est la prévention
le système de financement de la santé
d'assurance maladie est assez basique on
est malade on se fait soigner on se fait
rembourser ou pas la question qui se
pose est bien de savoir qui doit prendre
en main la prévention comment la
financer et comment la pratique et les
pouvoirs publics sécurité sociale le
monde associatif
peut-être aussi les professionnels de
santé
si on veut bien le reconnaître ce rôle
des actions des campagnes sont bien
menées et loin de moi lequel considéré
comme négligeable mais il ya encore
matière à réflexion pour une plus grande
efficacité au delà de la prévention
générale il faut revoir la situation
dans l'ensemble du système de santé de
la médecine du travail et de la médecine
scolaire
ces deux secteurs souffrent d'une
certaine marginalité alors qu'elles
représentent un potentiel de prévention
et de paix si ce dépistage aussi en
inscrivant ce débat aujourd'hui le rdse
a souhaité amorcer une réflexion de fond
pour que ce système de santé qui a été
longtemps un modèle puisse retrouver à
l'aube du xxième siècle sa grandeur au
service de nos concitoyens mais rien ne
se fera à son association de tous les
acteurs professionnels institutions
publiques ou privées financeurs patients
et où les pouvoirs publics ou bien sûr
leur place je vous remercie
merci monsieur barbier dans la suite des
débats la parole est à madame laurence
cohen pour le groupe crc
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues merci à monsieur
barbier au groupe rdse d'avoir proposé
ce débat notre république a placé la
santé la protection sociale
au rang de ces droits imprescriptibles
le préambule de la constitution la
charte universelle des droits de l'homme
le programme du conseil national de la
résistance sont fixés pour grandes
ambitions sociales de transformer en
droit quotidien ce qu'une minorité
considéré est accaparé en privilège la
santé et notre bien commun c'est
pourquoi aux logiques dominantes du
libéralisme à tout prix nous opposons
celle de justice sociale et de
solidarité
la santé est une préoccupation majeure
des citoyens pour lesquels il existe une
véritable attente de bénéficier d'un
système solidaire et de qualité notre
modèle de sécurité sociale est une
construction sociale historique qui
répondent à de véritables besoins mais
qui rencontrent des difficultés
structurelles auxquelles nous propose
une alternative celle d'une protection
sociale solidaire pour nous et bien au
delà notre sensibilité politique la
santé n'est pas une marchandise
selon un sondage de l'institut bbva 2
février 2014
les français ont une opinion positive de
leur système de protection sociale tels
qu'il est né à la libération la sécurité
sociale qui prévoit depuis 1948 un
financement de chacun en fonction de ses
moyens et une distribution en fonction
de ces besoins ne relève pas d'une
utopie dépassé ainsi 64% de nos
concitoyens ont jugé normal que la
france consacre un tiers du revenu
national au financement de la protection
sociale et neuf français sur dix
souhaitent que ce système demeure
essentiellement public
nous retiendrons également que sur six
français sur dix la qualité des soins
diffèrent selon les revenus
il s'agit d'un constat partagé et sans
cesse dénoncée par notre groupe d'une
fracture sociale dans l'accès aux soins
face au développement des inégalités
d'accès aux soins et de santé
face au vieillissement de la population
et au développement des maladies
chroniques
face à la dégradation de la qualité des
soins à la nécessité d'adapter les
prestations aux attentes nouvelles des
patients nous devons apporter une
réponse globale
la dynamique de privatisation et de
libéralisation notre système de santé ne
fait aucun doute pour nous et nous
regrettons vivement qu'il n'y ait
toujours pas de véritable rupture de
logique
malgré le changement de gouvernement la
question n'est pas tant de savoir si la
france a ou non le meilleur système de
santé du monde comme le suggérait le cda
en 2013 mais davantage de savoir le
niveau de responsabilité des lois
d'austérité sur la dégradation notre
système de santé
nous nous attarderons donc davantage sur
les effets négatifs des politiques
d'austérité menées successivement contre
notre modèle de santé et les
propositions alternatives que nous
formulons pour garantir une protection
sociale de haut niveau le système de
protection sociale a résisté
difficilement jusqu'à présent au cur de
raids de réductions budgétaires imposées
par les loi hpst l'instauration de la
tarification à l'activité
la réduction l'ondam il faut casser
c'est logique mortifère et abandonné à
la fois la loi hpst la tarification à
l'activité mais également augmenté
l'ondam faut-il rappeler ici que la
gauche rassemblée il n'y a pas si
longtemps partagé ses convictions cette
politique menée depuis trop longtemps a
des effets dramatiques alors que le
nombre de passages de passages aux
urgences a progressé de 75% entre 96 et
2011 fermeture et restructuration
d'établissements hospitaliers se sont
succédé touchant gravement de nombreuses
maternités qui ont été fermées au nom de
la rentabilité
ces fermetures de maternités sont allés
d'ailleurs de pair avec celle de centres
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
entraînant de graves conséquences sur le
choix des femmes les conditions de
travail du personnel médical se sont
inévitablement dégradé et continue de le
faire
nous assistons à une véritable stratégie
de transfert des pathologies courantes
et des population solvable sur le
système de santé privé pour nous
maintenir dans le secteur public que des
pathologies hautement coûteuse et les
populations les moins solvables
il ya une urgence démocratique à mettre
en place un système de santé solidaire
alternatif notre système de sécurité
sociale est basé vous
savez mes chers collègues sur une mise
en commun des cotisations des assurés
sociaux
le déséquilibre financiers rencontrés
par le régime général de la sécurité
sociale s'explique principalement par la
chute historique de la masse salariale
l'importance du taux de chômage et de la
précarité ainsi que par la signare et
financiarisation de l'économie
nous devons y ajouter le poids des
exonérations et des fraudes massives de
cotisations patronales
nous proposons en alternatif de
renforcer notre système de sécurité
sociale en assurant un financement plus
juste et plus efficace de nouvelles
ressources assurer à notre système une
meilleure santé sur jeu de mots
meilleure santé financière
en soumettant par exemple les revenus
financiers des entreprises à cotisations
ou en supprimant les exonérations dont
elle bénéficie actuellement sans oublier
la lutte contre la fraude patronale et
puis je le redis ici quand allons nous
prendre une mesure de justice
inscrite dans notre loi l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
ce sont 52 milliards de ressources
supplémentaires pour les caisses de
sécurité sociale
lever les freins concernant l'accès aux
soins passe notamment par la suppression
des franchises médicales véritable droit
d'entrer dans notre système de santé
nous portons au groupe crc un modèle de
sécurité sociale de prise en charge à
100% pour tous les assurés sociaux et
afin d'assurer une véritable démocratie
sanitaire
nous proposons de remplacer les agences
régionales de santé par des conseils
cantonaux de santé composé de
représentants de professionnels des élus
locaux et des usagers conseiller
coordonnée au niveau régional et
national
il ressent serait ainsi les besoins
santé validerait la réponse à ces
besoins a porté sur le territoire
concerné et contrôlerait
démocratiquement la réponse une
meilleure organisation des
établissements de santé donc nécessaire
pour garantir un accès simple et rapide
aux structures de soins et en finir avec
les déserts médicaux la relance de
l'hôpital public est une priorité qui
doivent se réaliser par un
investissement dans le financement est
également dans en termes de personnel
mais surtout penser la santé et l'accès
aux soins en termes de coopération et
non pas de concurrence
l'offre de santé doit permettre la prise
en charge d'un parcours de santé global
et cohérent
articulant la médecine de ville à
l'hôpital les centres de santé doivent
bénéficier de moyens à la hauteur de
leur mission que sont la délivrance des
soins ambulants poids ambulatoire la
prévention la promotion de la santé
l'éducation thérapeutique la pratique de
l'ibg ambulatoire le tiers payant
actuellement pratiqués par les centres
de santé permet de supprimer les
barrières d'accès aux soins et nécessite
une prise en charge meilleur par la
sécurité sociale le développement de la
médecine de qualité ambulatoire répond à
une évolution des attentes des patients
et de la technologie et les centres de
santé apporte la solution de proximité
d'accessibilité et de démocratie
sanitaire
je n'ai pas tant évidemment de
développer tout ce qu'il faut faire en
termes de prévention d'information de
dépistage est également de formation
médicale
mais je voudrais dire en tout cas que
pour nous il est extrêmement important
de supprimer les dépassements
d'honoraires pour réduire les inégalités
sociales d'accès aux soins
enfin la formation médicale doit être
visitée des mesures incitatives instauré
pour les futurs professionnels de santé
comme le financement des études en
échange de cinq années de travail dans
le service public ou dans les zones de
déserts médicaux comme cela est le cas
pour les enseignants pour concluant mes
chers collègues ayant inventé fait vivre
la sécurité sociale comme système de
santé la france un système de santé qui
ne doit pas se cantonner à une médaille
d'or sur le podium international
mais doit être un modèle à partager avec
les autres pays attaché à un
internationaliste progressis nous devons
être porteur d'exigence en termes de
coopération internationale et contribuer
à exporter notre système de santé
une nouvelle politique mondiale de santé
reste à inventer
basé sur la coopération plutôt que sur
la concurrence sur la satisfaction des
besoins des populations plutôt que sur
la recherche de profits pour une
minorité d'actionnaires je vous remercie
merci madame cohen la parole est à
monsieur françois fortassin pour le
groupe
rds eux
monsieur le président madame la
présidente des perdants madame la
ministre mes chers collègues notre
excellent collègue gilbert barbier a
posé le problème non seulement en tant
que est lui très intéressés par ces
questions mais surtout en tant que
médecin en ce qui me concerne je jouerai
plutôt une réaction de béotienne ou
comme tout un chacun nous sommes des
malades potentiels
donc ces problèmes peuvent nous
intéresser fortement
il faut dire que le système santé très
précieux jurés français parce qu'il
repose sur le principe de solidarité
envers les plus fragiles et qui lie à
renty à chacun l'accès à des soins de
qualité
notre système santé incarne les valeurs
humanistes qui sont au coeur du pacte
républicain selon une enquête réalisée à
mener 2014
à la demande de la fédération suisse
lire de france les français que le
considèrent que leur système santé
demeure un des meilleurs du monde sinon
le meilleur du monde
en revanche déplorent une mauvaise
répartition des médecins sur le
territoire national et ils ont aussi le
sentiment d'une médecine à deux vitesses
pour 92% des personnes interrogées les
patients qui ont de l'argent en plus de
possibilités de se faire soigner et 60%
74% pensent que les innovations et les
meilleurs traitements ne sont pas
proposées à tous les patients en effet
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
notre système de santé n'est plus
égalitaires et que des millions de
personnes en sont progressivement exclut
encore beaucoup de personnes renoncent à
se faire soigner pour des raisons
financières à cause notamment des
dépassements d'honoraires des médecins
qui affecte mouvement les salariés les
plus modestes
cela n'est pas tolérable nos concitoyens
ont en effet le droit de recourir quelle
que soit leur situation sociale à des
soins de qualité
je sais qu'un observatoire des
dépassements d'honoraires a été mis en
place et qu'un rapport a été remis il ya
quelques mois permettant de faire le
point de la situation
mais les inégalités en matière de santé
sont aussi territoriale est de plus en
plus de nos concitoyens notamment dans
les zones rurales sont touchés par les
difficultés d'accès aux soins qui sont
une réalité quotidienne c'est la
désertification médicale
le regroupement des professionnels
médicaux et paramédicaux dans des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires et
constitue une réponse précieuse la loi
hpst de 2009 autorisant les
collectivités à prendre en charge les
dossiers concernant la santé est un
progrès important
cependant il ya un certain nombre de
règles à observer d'abord le projet il
est judicieux que le projet immobilier
soient portés par des collectivités
territoriales communauté de communes
communes voire conseils généraux c'est
le ainsi qu'on assiste au partage de
l'espace des bâtiments et le projet de
santé porté par les médecins et les
paramédicaux
c'est le partage du dossier médical mais
aussi le partage de la clientèle et
l'offre de soins deviennent nos quasi
permanente
les médecins et les paramédicaux dégager
de problèmes matériels peuvent mettre en
place une politique de prévention qui
est extrêmement utile en matière de
santé et les maisons de santé offre une
entrée pour les jeunes mais 2,5 qui
répugne de plus en plus pour ne pas dire
que on en trouve plus qui s'installe de
façon individuelle les l'installation
tel qu'on l'a connu dans les amener par
c est à peu près terminée
donc ces maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires constitue une
ressource précieuse au problème de
l'équipement médical tant pour les
médecins que pour les patients et
participent pleinement à la diversité de
notre offre de soins la médecine
libérale évolué et le développement de
ces structures est indispensable pour
attirer les jeunes qui veulent de moins
en moins comme je les dis travailler
seul la mutualisation des ressources
médicales leur offre un certain confort
de travail et leur permet surtout
d'assurer un meilleur suivi des patients
il est en revanche nécessaire que ces
projets soient portés par les
collectivités jeu les dijonnais c'est
notamment le cas d'une maison de santé
que j'ai eu l'honneur d'inaugurer il y a
peu de temps dans les hautes-pyrénées
âme c'est à dire à loures barousse
il faut dire aussi que d'un problème se
pose c'est que la féminisation
extrêmement importante du métier de
médecin qu a fait que ça n'est pas la
qualité
peut-être d'ailleurs que les médecins
actuels sont beaucoup plus performants
que méritée les médecins il ya 40 ans
mais il ya une règle c'est qu'ils
passent moins de temps auprès de leurs
malades et il est évident que le
problème qui se pose quand même c'est
que les dames et c'est tout à leur
honneur ne peuvent pas exercer avec la
même le même détachement que les sommes
qu'ils peuvent consacrer à 100% leur
temps à la médecine et ça n'est
peut-être pas le cas des dames et si je
dis bien que c'est à leur honneur
mais c'était une problème à prendre en
compte
quand on regarde bien entendu la façon
dont peut-être exercer la médecine
il faudrait envisager d'autre part
d'autres éléments sont à prendre en
compte notamment envisagé l'approbation
des traitements associés les patients au
processus de décision vient d eux des
outils d'évaluation au long cours qui
correspondent réellement à leurs
attentes
le dispositif possible actuellement au
sein des agences sanitaires
les patients doivent pouvoir évaluer
eux-mêmes en termes d'efficacité et
d'impact sur la qualité de vie les
bénéfices et traitement afin que les
investissements supporté par la
collectivité nationale soit pertinent
pour les personnes qui luttent au
quotidien avec leurs maladies et leurs
traitements
je souhaite également aborder la
question de l'insuffisance parfois de la
formation des médecins généralistes en
matière de prise en charge des
addictions
ainsi en matière de prise en charge la
dépendance ou les principaux
prescripteurs de traitement de
substitution de médecine de ville somme
pour 98 % des médecins généralistes
or trop peu de ses médecins généralistes
ont reçu au cours de leur formation
un module sur les addictions leur
permettant d'une part une prévention
individuelles ciblées et d'autre part
une prise en charge adéquate
c'est une madame la ministre nous semble
urgent que le prochain projet de loi de
santé prévoit la création de modules de
cycle universitaire d'études médicales
afin que les médecins généralistes en
particulier des zones rurales dispose de
l'ensemble des outils nécessaires à une
prise en charge efficace et sécurisée
des façades dépendent gros et je vais
terminer la médecine qui peut être
libéral dans son exercice doit être
soumise à la puissance publique en
matière d'organisation et c'est
peut-être là où le bât blesse
mais nous restons quand même optimiste
parce que notre système de santé
s'il n'est pas le meilleur du monde
reste extrêmement performant
merci monsieur fortassin de la parole
l'état monsieur jeu marival ehrenberg
pour le groupe
udi uc
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme vous le savez
la semaine dernière la cour des comptes
a rendu public son rapport sur les
maternités commandé par notre commission
des affaires sociales et dont les
conclusions ne sont pas des plus
optimistes la cour y révèle en effet
qu'en dix ans la france est passé du 6e
au 17e rang européen en terme de
mortalité néonatale et ce alors je
rappelle aussi qu'elle se situe au
premier rang au taux de fécondité à la
lueur de ce classement
la question de notre excellent collègue
gilles barbier prend toute sa dimension
et j'en profite pour le remercier au nom
de notre groupe udi us et de l'avoir
posée ce que l'on observe à l'échelon
des maternités se retrouve-t-il à celui
de l'ensemble du système de santé voilà
la question
et c'est cette inquiétude qu'elle
exprime salle de voir nos performances
de santé se dégrade et relativement
rapport à celle des autres pays l'oscd
la question telle qu'elle est posée est
révélatrice à la fois une inquiétude
mais aussi de l'image positive que les
français se font de leur système de
santé
une image exprimée par jean de
kervasdoué qui dans son carnet de santé
de la france 2012 se félicitait d'être
français après chaque séjour à
l'étranger et de jouir de ce seul fait
d'un système d'une telle généreuse
qualité alors la france at elle jamais
eu le meilleur système de santé au monde
c'est aussi la question qu'il faut se
poser dans l'affirmative
est-il vraiment menacés voire des gens
déclin
premier élément de réponse si l'état de
santé les français continuent
s'améliorer en revanche ils progressent
moins vite que dans plusieurs autres
pays
le problème donc viendrai moins de la
dégradation de notre système que de
l'amélioration des performances des
autres
de fait la france demeure bien classé
sur un certain nombre d'indicateurs
déterminant elle se classe par exemple
au neuvième rang des pays occidentaux
pour l'espérance de vie est au troisième
rang pour la marque
la mortalité par crise cardiaque
accident vasculaire
de plus on peut noter que certaines des
contre-performances françaises n'ont
rien à voir avec la qualité du système
de santé puisqu'elles sont directement
imputables aux modes de vie
la france demeure par exemple numéro un
pour la consommation d'alcool et le
tabagisme progresse fortement surtout
chez les femmes
enfin jugé le système de santé français
globalement c'est faire fi des
inégalités qui le traverse et qui sont
tant socioculturel que territoriales
mais l'exercice est tout de même
incontournable pour l'accomplir plus
avant il convient de se mettre d'accord
sur ce qui est bon pour le système de
santé ensuite trouver les données
comparatives ce chiffre est plus précise
et je crois qu'un système de santé peut
être jugé à l'aune de deux critères le
premier bien entendu le service qu'il
rend aux patients et le second son
efficience c'est à dire le rapport entre
les moyens engagés
elle édite performance quant aux données
chiffrées
elles font parfois cruellement défaut
surtout pour disposer d'un benchmarking
actualisé
c'est par exemple pour cela qui nous a
fallu commander à la cour des comptes un
rapport sur les maternités
cela dit il semblerait bien que tant du
point de vue de la qualité médicale du
service rendu que son efficience notre
système de santé puissent bénéficier de
substantielles marge d'amélioration
ainsi le dernier rapport du haut conseil
de la santé publique
révèle-t-il que la mortalité prématurée
des hommes recensant les décès survenant
avant 65 ans est élevé en france cet
indicateur classe notre pays au 14e rang
sur 26 pays de l'union européenne une
contre performance qui s'explique par un
autre indicateur alarmant la france se
classe défavorablement pour les cancers
en particulier chez les hommes et la
santé au travail pose aussi problème si
l'on considère le mauvais classement
pour les accidents du travail
qu'en est il donc de l'efficience du
système autrement dit le rapport entre
ses moyens et ses résultats
ce n'est pas compliqué la france est le
pays européen où la part des dépenses de
santé dans le pib le plus élevé elle
représente 11,2 pour cent près du double
d'un pays comme l'estonie qui il est
vrai est à l'autre extrémité du
classement
là où le bât blesse c'est que ces moyens
globaux ne se retrouvent plus là où les
attendrait une fois que l'on regarde
dans le détail
ainsi en termes de lits d'hôpitaux
disponibles par cent mille personnes
la france se situe au huitième rang
européen au 17e rang pour ce qui est des
sirènes et au 20e rang pour les scanners
et pour ce qui est du nombre de médecins
l'activité elle se situe très légèrement
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne
idem pour les vaccinations en revanche
la france demeure bien le premier
consommateur européen de médicaments le
haut conseil pour l'avenir de
l'assurance maladie a de longue date
souligné que le poids du médicament dans
le pib était le plus élevé d'europe
le constat n'est donc pas nouveau le
système de santé français juste derrière
celui des etats-unis et des pays bas le
plus cher au monde sans pour autant que
le niveau de santé des français sont en
corrélation parce que la santé parce que
santé et médecine ne sont pas synonymes
je ne vous l'apprends pas si les moyens
alloués à la santé sont donc bien en
décalage
avec ces résultats c'est parce que le
système souffre d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements qu'a souligné tout à
l'heure gilbert barbier des
dysfonctionnements qui sont maintenant
bien identifié des réformes successives
et je pense en particulier à la création
de l'ondam au passage à la t2a la loi du
sur le parcours de soins à la loi hpst
ont tâché d'y remédier la création des
ars en particulier à constitue à mes
yeux une avancée notable dans la
coordination des moyens mais beaucoup
reste à faire
c'est la raison d'être de la prochaine
étant attendu loi de santé madame la
ministre
mais aura-t-elle les moyens de ses
ambitions
sans vouloir déflorer le débat qui nous
attend prochainement je constate
qu'effectivement certains aspects du
projet initial sont encourageants c'est
le cas de toutes les mesures qu'ils
entendent décloisonner le système ainsi
en est il de la coordination des
parcours de soins complexes de
l'instauration d'un document de liaison
entre les services de soin en ville et
l'hôpital et de la relance du dossier
médical personnel
ces initiatives sont nature notamment à
réduire les actes redondant inutiles qui
représente je le rappelle 28% de
l'activité selon notre nex une vingtaine
de milliards d'économies potentielles
c'est d'ailleurs exactement ce que
j'avais proposé au nom de cette haute
assemblée en tant que rapporteur général
sur le plfss en matière hospitalière
un chantier doit être ouvert d'urgence
il concerne la carte spital hier le
rapport de la cour des comptes sur les
maternités dont je faisais état au début
d'intervention le révèle la vesle bien
que sa réforme n'est pas achevé
il s'agit là non seulement d'une
question déficiences mais aussi et
surtout tu sécurité de qualité de
service rendu qui tire notre système de
santé vers le bas ensuite en matière
ambulatoire faut engager une véritable
lutte contre la désertification médicale
que les mesures incitatives déjà prises
n'ont pas fait reculer sans oublier
l'accès difficile que souligné
aussi gilbert barbier à certaines à
certains spécialistes
enfin je conclurai en évoquant deux
sujets transverses et majeur le premier
celui la prévention ça fait maintenant
plus de dix ans que la france est
supposé s'être dotée d'une politique de
prévention digne de ce nom
dans les faits elle tarde pourtant à
faire sentir ses effets alors je pose la
question
hocine iconoclaste soit elle peut-on
vraiment faire de la prévention
je veux dire en attend vraiment les
moyens
ou n'est-ce qu'un voeu pieux il ya au
moins un domaine où cela semble possible
c'est celui de la iatrogénie
médicamenteuse
ce qui m'amène au second sujet
transverse que je voulais évoquer les
records que la france bat en matière
d'infections iatrogènes est la
conséquence directe de notre culture de
la consommation du médicament
le médicament ne peut plus être
considéré comme un produit de
consommation courante
cela passe par une éducation du patient
et donc de la prévention et une
rationalisation voire une réduction des
prescriptions
donc prenons ces directions orientons
nous dans ce dans cette sur ces axes et
peut-être pourrons-nous un jour madame
la ministre dire de nouveau et mon cher
collègue dire de nouveau que nous avons
le meilleur système de santé au monde
merci monsieur valeur enberg la parole
l'état président alain milon vous avez
la parole monsieur le président
bien madame madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
si la question que nous nous posons
aujourd'hui est claire et directe
reconnaissons que la réponse à y
apporter n'est pas aussi simple et
facile qu'on pourrait le croire
déjà nous partons d'un constat
indéniable
la france a eu le meilleur système de
santé au monde
qu'en est il aujourd'hui elles
atteignent toujours aujourd'hui
selon roger salomon qui préside vous le
savez le haut conseil de santé publique
en matière de santé la france est
aujourd'hui un pays moyen parfois
meilleurs que certains mais pas toujours
de son côté dans son édition 2013 du
panorama de la santé l'eau c d e conclu
que le système de santé en france
demeure globalement performant et
efficace tout en ayant engagé des
efforts de rationalisation
il continue d'assurer l'une des
meilleure prise en charge des coûts de
la santé de la population parmi les pays
dotés d eux
mais il faut noter toutefois que la
pérennité du système pourrait être
menacée par un renouvellement
insuffisant de la population médicale
pour répondre à la question à l'ordre du
jour de notre séance
je pense que nous devons faire une
analyse à la fois dans le temps et dans
l'espace
la recherche de la qualité fait
aujourd'hui partie de notre quotidien
pour la mesure et des normes et des
référentiels ont été instaurées plus
aucun domaine professionnel ne semble y
échapper mais qu'en est-il de la qualité
de notre système de santé
toutes les études concordent pour
montrer que celle ci
laisse clairement à désirer sans aller
jusqu'à dire que le choix a sciemment
été fait de ne pas dépister l'erreur il
faut s'intéresser interrogé sur la
raison de la persistance de tels
insuffisances le soin a toujours été en
évolution constante
mais il a connu ces dernières années des
changements considérables à la fois sur
le plan technico économique spirituel et
anthropologique les progrès techniques
et organisationnelles récents l'ont
rendu vraiment efficace
initialement d'essence religieuse il ne
se réfère plus aujourd'hui à aucune
transcendance la personne bénéficiaire
pour des raisons médicales ou social
était considéré il y à peu comme étant
passive et assister elle est maintenant
définies par ces droits est convoqué
comme acteur principal du processus de
soin l'hôpital et les établissements de
santé doivent faire face aujourd'hui à
de nombreuses mutations avec des
incidences incontournable sur les
pratiques des professionnels
si ce phénomène n'est pas nouveau il
s'est considérablement accéléré ces
dernières années suscitant au mieux des
interrogations au pire des inquiétudes
et des blocages les établissements de
soins ont pendant les trente glorieuses
et gilbert barbier l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure bénéficier d'un développement
continu accentuant leur modernisation et
déployant leurs plateaux techniques sans
forcément analyser et prendre en
considération ce qui est souvent mise en
avant par les patients techniques de
plus en plus sophistiqués et
yves ressenti de déshumanisation
cloisonnement entre services repli des
établissements sur eux-mêmes
morcellement des tâches dues à l'hyper
spécialisation
depuis quelques années les pays
européens pour ne prendre que l'exemple
de ce qui nous est proche se trouvent
confrontés à la même problématique
ils doivent garantir une offre de soins
de qualité adaptée aux besoins de la
population est accessible à tous et ceci
dans un contexte de ressources publiques
limitées l'europe est à la croisée des
chemins
tout au moins en ce qui concerne la
politique de santé une politique de
santé fermement augment des
gouvernements nationaux qui souhaite
qu'il en reste ainsi
cela n'est probablement pas surprenant
si on sait que la santé absorbe
désormais plus ou moins 10% du pib des
pays les plus riches
d'ailleurs de nombreux changements
intervenus dans les systèmes de santé
ces dix dernières années se sont
concentrés sur le resserrement du
contrôle économique plutôt que sur la
promotion d'une bonne santé les
ministères des finances ont une forte
oserais-je dire trop forte influence sur
la politique de la santé
les différences d'espérance de vie en
europe montrent cependant l'étendue des
enjeux politiques
nous avons la science nous avons le
savoir pour réduire radicalement ce
fossé mais cela exige une volonté
politique
l'organisation et le financement pour
prendre des actions décisives
ainsi la philosophie du marché qui est
au coeur de l'union européenne aggravent
la situation des pays les plus pauvres
au moins à court terme
ils perdent leur professionnel de santé
qui migrent vers les pays les plus
riches pour des postes mieux payés les
interventions en santé les plus
efficientes
elle que changer de style de vie de
style de vie requiert des
investissements de long terme dans
d'autres secteurs économiques que ceux
d'à santé l'oscd eux attribuent
d'ailleurs la faible espérance de vie
dans les pays les plus pauvres à une
mortalité plus élevée due à l'appareil
circulatoire ou duo cirrhose du foie qui
reflète des styles de vie d'abus de
tabac et de consommation d'alcool
il faut aussi y ajouter un taux de
suicides masculins très élevé le dilemme
politique et que les dépenses de santé
ne se réduisent pas quand bien même les
investissements pour promouvoir de
meilleures mode de vie réussisse et que
les citoyens vivent plus vieux il reste
toujours d'autres années de vie en bonne
santé a gagné et des progrès en qualité
de vie que les citoyens en meilleure
santé sont en droit d'attendre en france
comme d'ailleurs dans de nombreux pays
européens dans le domaine de la santé le
marché opère de façon imparfaite
il est généralement adapté pour générer
de l'efficience dans les services de
chirurgie programmée mais beaucoup moins
pour fournir des soins d'urgence et des
soins de longue durée pour des patients
chroniques cela risque d'être encore
plus significatif quand on voit les
transferts de services publics à des
prestataires privés à but lucratif ou
non les coûts à court terme et les gains
d'efficience peuvent être équilibré ou
moins dans due aux moindres du fait des
difficultés que cela génère pour les
épées des hôpitaux du secteur public qui
se retrouvent dans les cas les plus
complexes et les urgences le coût du
médicament et jean marie vanlerenberghe
on a un peu parlé reste aussi un sujet
clé de discussion alors que la plupart
des médicaments dans les dépenses de
santé continue de croître
si une réponse a été de persuader les
prescripteurs de se tourner vers le
générique traditionnellement moins cher
l'industrie pharmaceutique affirme que
ces écoutes sont élevés du fait des
énormes investissements de duos
développement
en dépit du manque d enthousiasme pour
une politique de santé radical il faudra
bien se montrer plus offensif en matière
de santé publique par la promotion de
modes de vie touchant la santé par la
prévention et pas la protection de la
santé des citoyens
pour en revenir plus précisément au
système de santé français et son
évolution si les français bénéficie
d'une des meilleures couvertures maladie
au monde
il me semble essentiel de noter que pour
rester performant le monde du soin doit
s'adapter à la nouvelle donne
démographique techniques économiques et
même spirituelles il doit se situer à la
circulation entre le privé et le public
car il touche à l'intimé mais en même
temps il est pris en charge par la
société
ils concernent ainsi les pouvoirs
publics les médias les associations et
les citoyens que nous sommes tous la
qualité
madame la ministre ne se décrète pas
elle se mesurerait vous savez bien étant
médecin vous même elle est par ailleurs
intimement liés à l'évaluation à toutes
les évaluations celle des outils celle
des traitements et de leur impact sur
l'espérance de vie
mais la première des évaluations portent
d'abord sur la performance des individus
et sur les performances des structures
c'est d'ailleurs à ce titre que la haute
autorité de santé avait retenu la mise
en oeuvre de l'évaluation des pratiques
professionnelles
le pp comme un élément majeur de la
modernisation du système de santé
mes chers collègues personne n'échappe
au débat sur la santé en france
la maîtrise des coûts de santé est
désormais un débat récurrent
la france dépense beaucoup pour sa santé
avec des résultats qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur de ses investissements at on
coutume de dire
le haut conseil de santé publique
relativise cette position
certes la part du pib a loué la santé en
france est élevé proche toutefois de
celle de l'allemagne
de l'autriche et de la belgique mais un
autre classement stigmatise mois notre
pays
l'hémicycle du sénat